to watch you early on in your career
like you said you was the happy one you
was the kid that carried the backpack
nike started a backpack line because
and you to this day you still carry your
backpack all the time um and so there's
this common misconception that you're
not
the kid that carries the backpack
anymore i still think you're the kid
that loves basketball and carry a
backpack yeah but
over the course of the years your
answers
to the media how you deal with the media
has changed
why is that is that just who you grew
into as that because of the way they act
with certain [ __ ] where did that
i felt like the media knew more than me
i almost had them on a pedestal of like
they got more history knowledge of the
game they more experienced to me in this
area of the nba so once i started to get
more experience and realize like oh no
they can never be
what i am or know what i know
or understand it the way i understand it
some of the questions you know they
didn't seem so intelligent to me anymore
people wanted to praise me more than i
liked or
hate me more than i like make a big deal
out of so much other [ __ ] i was just
like you know this game is simple to me
so some of the stuff that you're asking
really doesn't move me the way it used
to i just you know start to see life
different i can see this game different
so you know
of course my
answers and questions you know about
what goes on is going to be different
too so i just chalk that up to just
maturity and experience
and speaking of media uh social media
obviously
we were teammates when you when you got
caught with the burner
one thing i loved about the burner
account is
everything that you said on the burner
account you just started to say on kevin
durant's account yeah a lot of people
don't like it as you know most people
voice they don't like how you
respond to some fans or how you respond
to this how you are always tweeting what
do you make of people's reaction to you
responding to fans and if you think
something you send it yeah i just think
people are still upset that i went to
the warriors and a lot of people who are
cavs fans who
enjoyed watching the cavs beat y'all
before
um which is a lot of people i didn't
realize that i got
a lot of people enjoyed seeing y'all
lose in 2016.
and a lot of those people were upset
that we were so good and they're still
upset
because you do the same [ __ ] on twitter
damian lillard does the same [ __ ] on
twitter cj mccullum does the same [ __ ]
on twitter we all do the same [ __ ] on
twitter but for me it's a problem i mean
i chalk it up to just me being so good
at what i do
and playing with a team that was so
great
and we fit so well nobody likes a great
thing
and i was i guess i was the cause of
that
great thing because i came and joined so
it's way deeper than what i do on
twitter and i understand that and it's
funny to me at this point because you
can't race what we did you're never
going to race it and you know you love
watching us play
you know what i'm saying so the best i
think it's the best era basketball ever
but that's really what it is so many
people still upset with me that i chose
to play basketball for the golden state
warriors which is sad at this point
because it's almost a decade later
since i made that decision you know what
i'm saying that's never going to stop me
from engaging with fans because at the
end of the day i'm only talking about
basketball i'm not diving into politics
i'm not telling you how you should live
i'm not flexing my money or my power or
none of that you know you i'm just
literally talking about the game you
know and what i see and i don't think it
harms anyone